you all know that this is not a
conspiracy theory program I am not
particularly conspiratorial by my nature
so today I have to tell you that the
Nevada State election of the Nevada
Democratic Party has hired a former
Buddha edge staffer after Buddha judge
behaved weirdly when it came to the Iowa
caucus now I am NOT saying that this is
part of a concerted effort for Pete
Buddha judge to steal the Nevada caucus
I am telling you that it's evidence of
the way to incest incestuous nature of
politics in the United States and how
the same people keep showing up in too
many places for my comfort and this is a
story in that it is getting a lot of
attention and we have to figure out what
it is that is and is not going on I will
tell you what I know I will tell you
what the Nevada state Democratic Party
has said and then you tell me what you
think the Nevada Democratic Party hired
a former paid Pete Budaj edge organizer
to be their voter protection director
her name is Emily Goldman when you
looked at her LinkedIn page yesterday
you saw that she started a job this
month as voter protection director for
the Nevada state Democratic Party her
last job until starting this one up to
and including this month was organizer
for Pete Budaj edges campaign Pete for
America this already just doesn't look
great given the theories that are
floating around about the connections
between Pete's campaign and the Iowa
caucus and the developer of the app that
was used to transmit results even
without going conspiratorial the way
some people are doing it just doesn't
look good people noticed this yesterday
and it started to get attention
yesterday and it didn't look good to a
lot of people
Emily Goldman also tweeted late last
week some personal professional news
I've joined the Nevada state Democratic
Party as their voter protection director
DM me if you're interested in
volunteering to help us ensure that
every voter is able to get the
assistance they need as soon as this
blew up Emily Goldman has locked her
Twitter account you now have to
she has to accept you in order for you
to see her tweets and also completely
removed her employment history from her
LinkedIn altogether and if you go now
and look at her LinkedIn profile there
is no employment history it just skips
right to her educational history no
record of working for Pete and then the
Nevada Democratic Party no matter what
you think about nefarious forces working
behind the scenes to steal the election
in Nevada for Pete Buddha judge this
just looks bad and of course the most
likely explanation for her scrubbing the
LinkedIn and then making her Twitter
private is that she's getting harassed
and bullied that that to me makes much
more sense than she thinks that by doing
that this controversy is going to go
away because clearly it's not so let me
be like extra close crystal-clear I
think if you have a good plan to steal
the Nevada caucuses for Pete Budaj edge
you don't have to hire people who work
for him to vote to go and work for the
party in Nevada you do it in a more
sophisticated way with technology or
with people whose work history wouldn't
directly point to Pete Buddha judge
anyone clever enough to steal the caucus
wouldn't have to resort to such an
obvious attention-grabbing tactic in
order to steal the Nevada caucus the
Nevada Democratic Party was asked about
this they put out a statement saying
that Emilie Goldman's position is going
to handle planning for the general
election in November and that she has no
decision-making role in the upcoming
caucuses on February 22nd and even if
she did they say there's no one person
in a role like this who could actually
affect or change the results that's
their position
another point to mention is that if you
actually want to steal the election with
dirty tricks it's true that even if she
were involved in the the caucuses on the
22nd the voter protection director
probably isn't the person you need since
they are unlikely to actually be able to
mess with vote totals or do the things
that are being alleged were done in Iowa
by the people who believe those theories
but it just looks terrible and it's more
about the fluidity with which people
move between working for candidates and
the party which is
actually not unusual people move all the
time between candidates and party think
back to the 2016 Republican primary into
the general election Sean Spicer was RNC
I believe it was communications director
or something during the Republican
primary he moved very swiftly into
voting for Donald Trump it happens both
ways but when the Democratic Party
nationally has been accused in 2016 and
now in 2020 of working to help certain
candidates at the expense of others
people are obviously going to react this
way and of course are going to be more
suspicious then you add to this that
Nevada was scheduled to use the exact
same app that imploded in Iowa for their
upcoming caucus but have since changed
their minds and things look weird and
they one could surmise motive to figure
out other ways to take control of the
caucus given that the app will not be
used so I understand why people are
flipping out the reality is there's lots
of DNC people and party people working
for Biden and vice versa
anybody with establishment connections
is likely to have the employment
fluidity going on tell me what you
believe and I think it's really
important you know once we start saying
not that the DNC has a preference which
obviously they do and we talked about in
2016 once we start saying there is a
conspiracy to manipulate vote totals we
are crossing a line that is a very
significant line to be crossing and so
what I want to hear from you is what you
make of this is this the incestuous
nature of party politics in the United
States is it more nefarious let me know
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show and boy
do we have a full one for you today